[Music]
big chunk of the movie takes place on
Luke's islands skellig michael which is
this bird sanctuary of the southwest
coast of ireland when we were at Skellig
and we saw the puffins frank said we
should have something like this that
exists in the island and that was the
genesis to the porks Ryan dreamed up
porks pores are the new prophecy Mikasa
Neil and his team design and then cooked
of these creatures with sketches our
concept team literally start to
freestyle different designs these are
some of the very very early sketches
that's the essence is this very simple
shape the design phase lasted two or
three weeks where we just generated a
multitude of different looks it's just
an egg with wings eyes at the very top
this little curve there and it's sad
little now the one that Ryan took to was
something very very simple Ryan's like
yes that's what I imagined them to be
then in the weeks and months after that
it gets honed and home to the point
where that's it the final design
[Music]